hey guys if you're new here my name is
Daniel and welcome to dlm men's
lifestyle consider subscribing because
on this channel we have a lot of cool
stuff for men in this video I'm going to
show you 10 things that every man should
have in his bedroom now of course there
are a lot more but in this video I'm
just gonna stick to 10. I would love to
hear your ideas at the end of this video
as well let's not waste any more time
guys let's get to it
[Music]
the first thing is a phone charger this
is just a no-brainer in today's world
you need a phone that's fully charged
all the time and the best way to help
you with that is to keep a charger in
your bedroom and in your car
next up a mirror preferably a full body
mirror just to double check your overall
look before you leave the bedroom
especially if you have guests over just
staying over the night and you wake up
in the morning and you go out of your
room you want to look at least a little
bit presentable so you just double check
in the mirror before you go
a security weapon especially if you live
in a country like South Africa where I
do I mean it's crazy dangerous here and
you never know what might happen at any
time so you want a weapon close to you
that you can protect yourself and your
family grab anything that can help even
a spear gun can do the trick but if you
have a bit of money just get a real gun
there's nothing better than a gun to
scare off unwelcome guests in your house
and if you don't like guns then just get
a fake gun you know a strong weapon but
that looks like a real gun it can be a
pepper gun or a co2 powered weapon you
choose now it can still cause some
damage but you probably won't kill
someone you can get it from tactical
monkeys or any other website I'll add
all the links of all the things I'm
talking about in the video description
down below for you so it's just a bit
easier
[Music]
water water is life I always keep water
right next to me just for when I get
thirsty and it's great to have it there
when you wake up because your body needs
it to flush out all the toxins you can
keep a glass or even a nice bottle
like this one it really keeps the water
nice and cold
good quality bed bed sheets and a pillow
I mean this is just a must think about
it there are 24 hours a day if you sleep
eight hours that's one third of your day
one third of your life that you will
spend on a bed so from all the things
that you still want to buy in life it
makes sense to invest just a little bit
in a good quality bed
[Music]
foreign
book and pen for some reason or it
happens to me a lot ideas just pop into
your head when you're in bed and if you
don't want to forget them you need a
book and a pen next to you just to write
them down
alarm clock now I know you can set your
alarm on your phone a lot of people do
that but personally I just like the old
classic alarm clocks it's just something
about it and if you struggle to wake up
you need one that's loud
a bed lamp this is another no-brainer
because if you wake up in the middle of
the night you need to go to the toilet
or you're bored you can't sleep you just
need to read a little bit then just put
on the light
a candle it just needs to be somewhere
in your bedroom where you can get it
especially if you have a awesome wife
just to have that romantic moment or
when you experience load chatting in
South Africa that means power outages
yes that does happen here and they steal
the cables a lot
the last one
a Bible the best for last
keep it read it and study it for me I
use it to start and finish my day the
right way I cannot even begin to tell
you how the truth of this book changed
my life and it will change yours as well
if you are open to it if you are open to
it check out this video here from my
other channel where I talk more about my
spiritual relationship with God I'll see
you there and always remember before you
go life is short so don't waste yours
search guys